hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the Magnus invitational we
are continuing with the match Magnus
Carlsen versus ding leerin to see who
will face him Cara Nakamura in the
finals so this is Game one and well
we're all very eager to see what Magnus
prepared for ding as well two days ago
when they played it was just you know
Kings gambit Vienna game h5 Rosalie mo a
lot of crazy stuff so let's see what
what he came up with for this one so he
opens with the d4 and Bing replies
Knight to f6
we have Knight to f3 b5 biding and now
Bishop to f4 still continuing to use his
London system we have E 6 and now Knight
B to d2 now he prefers prefers this line
then the Knight to c3 1 we have Bishop
to d6 now to here challenging the dark
square Bishop and Bishop to g5 now here
at dingos back Bishop to e7 he doesn't
want the night to be pinned and III now
by Magnus with castles biding and Bishop
to d3 b 6 preparing to fin get to the
light square bishop and here there is
one game in the database were Knights
that if I was played but here we have
Quinta e 2 and it is as a move 8 do we
have a completely new game so here ding
just continues Bishop to d7 Bishop to b7
he wants to play Knight b7 get the rook
the c8 push c5 and play a normal game
but Magnus decides to go for Bishop
captures and f6 Bishop captures and h4
the the so called caveman attack I think
says I'm not very impressed by this he
goes Knight to d7 and here
ding spent some 30 30 seconds maybe on
this move whereas Carlsen used used up
already some 5 minutes to get to this
position and here dink has to be sure
that this is not an option because after
captures captures and check you you do
not go back and allow Queen - Queen to
h5 you have to go to h6 and then it's
gonna be a wild game but still black
will prevail ending of course knows how
to defend these positions very well for
example after g4 you're gonna go g6
Knight captures on f7 a nice fork here
with check after the rook captures gonna
go g5 would check but after the King
goes back
Charis Charis and you don't have you
don't have compensation for the piece
black black is very happy playing
playing this position being a piece up
so just Knight to g5 by Magnus now okay
there is the threat against the h7 pawn
and ding just goes h6 d h b h7 pawn is
no longer a threat and now well you
obviously have to consider knife to h7
but then just to work the EI tand you
don't mind Knight captures Bishop but
instead Magnus goes for f4 he offers up
this night and it's not really an offer
because if you capture the knight then
you have this tricky Bishop to h7 check
and it doesn't matter if the King moves
or captures then it's queen h5 check
King moves and after this captures you
do not stop checkmate if g6 of course
Queen h7 then is checkmate
so after this f4 idea thing just
continues with c5 he says I'm still not
impressed here there's nothing going on
on the Kings side we have c3
strengthening the center here and just
Bishop back to e7 preparing the nights
to come to f6 and g4 by Magnus now
Magnus is ready to go back with the
night and start pushing the Jeep on so
Knight to f6 ding just consolidates here
and a three now making improving the
position on the Queen side a little bit
now that if black decides to push c4 or
something like that it will be
problematic for black later on to push
to b4 and b5 in b4 and the white will be
able to Castle queenside so ding just
continues rook the c8 and now Queen to
g2 preparing to put the knight back and
then play g5 hopefully open up the G
file and so on
we have Bishop to d6 biting and now
Knight G to f3 now preparing g5 and here
ding trades 1c capture C captures and
Knight to e4 blocking this LightSquared
bishop and well there's always this
pressure on the knight on D - so Magnus
continues pushing we have g5 ending of
course closes the position with with h5
we have Knights the e5 by Magnus and now
first night capture Sundy - with Queen
captures and now g6 and this is not a
very solid setup King f2 by Magnus he
wants to improve the safety of his King
and King - g7 not allowing any Knight
capture Sanji
yes in the future and rook ate the c1
now trying to trade off a pair of rooks
along the C file but also just claiming
the C file now we have Queen to e7
developing the Queen connecting rooks
and the Queen to e2 now maybe with ideas
of Bishop to e6 training of the the
light square bishop although it's hard
to say as this bishop is is very good
while this bishop not really doing all
that much so rook the c7 black now wants
to double up on the C file and here
Magnus trades once with characters
captures and rook to d1 now we have
worked the c8 grabbing hold of the C
file but now rook to d1 I worked the d2
not allowing in any infiltrations along
the second-ranked even if the the
bishops are traded off so Queen to c1
and here you don't want to allow
something like Queen to h1 and then
you'll have to worry about any checks
the h4 pond and so on so Queen to d1
Magnus blocks and offers a queen trade
which being happily accepts with
captures captures and here ding
eliminates the strong knight on e5
Bishop captures F captures in the now
King to f8 nothing starts improving the
position of the King the king side is
pretty pretty solid so you want to shoot
the King over to the Queen side king te
to Magnus does the same and now King to
e7 now we have King Tubby 2 and here
just rook to c7 ding says ok I'm calling
this a draw but Magnus not yet convinced
convinced he goes for b4 we have a six
now just keeping the pawns like this and
then whichever pawn Magnus decides the
push ding will just block it block the
position accordingly so Magnus goes for
a4 and now look back to c8 mighting and
here Carlsen goes for Luke to f1 saying
that he's maybe interested in in rook to
f6 followed by Bishop captures and g6
which means that he would maybe give up
the bishop for these two pawns then
maybe the rook could pick up this pawn
as well and this bishop is well very
poorly placed not really doing all that
much so it might be worth a shot
thing says Luke d8 I'm still just gonna
make moves and wait to see what you're
gonna do and Magnus goes for it rook to
f6 but the ding doesn't allow it dingos
if you go look to see it then maybe we
would see something like this but it's
hard to save this Bishop can
become useful since there really is no
way for it to enter the game whatever
you do you might even go for this pawn
and then it's who knows what might
happen
so the instead goes rook 2g8 he doesn't
know how this Bishop captures in g6 idea
and now Magnus pushes a 5 we have b5 now
the Queen side is also completely
blocked off and wrote back to f1 by
Magnus we worked the c8 and here
rook the c1 we have a roof trade
captures captures and now Bishop the c6
ding says I am now ready to call this a
draw but Magnus not yet not yet a
convinced king b2 we have King to d7 and
now King to e 2 we have king te 7 and
here Magnus decides to make a little job
for the end of the game he decides to go
for Bishop captures and g6 so he gives
up a piece but the there's nothing being
can do about it because Dean captures
but there is no way to get to the king
inter game and there is no way to get
the Bishop into the game because all of
the pawns are on light squares but there
just wasn't a way for Magnus to take
advantage of this so of course they
played a few moves king d2 Bishop to d7
just repeating a few times King g1
bishop c6 king b2 Bishop d7 King you
want and here once again and it was in
this position that today agree to a draw
or rather it is a draw by threefold
repetition so very exciting game one at
the caveman attack by the London from
Magnus and ding not very impressed by he
just kept it cool and they decided to
draw the game with the black pieces and
now we'll see what ding does with the
white pieces so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Kevin Jayla bias
Charles McDonald is jicama du Lieber
ollie John Hyde and non-stop grind for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnus invitational
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Saturday